another day another boat of migrants
arriving on the kent coast among them a
family of four taking their first steps
in what they hope will be a new life as
the government here insists its
relationship with france to stem the
crossings is working well
all i can say is that we've worked very
effectively with the french government
so far
we've had 300 arrests we've worked with
them to to do that they've been 65
convictions
and we both accept that there are
something like 13 500 crossings that
have been prevented through our working
together so it is a good collaborative
relationship
624 migrants reached the uk on friday
the fourth highest daily tally of this
current crisis while 491 made it across
including a newborn baby it brings the
total arrival since the start of the
year to more than eighteen thousand
i can't obviously put myself in the
shoes of someone in such a desperate
situation that a newborn baby has made
that absolutely perilous crossing but
that also illustrates when we see a
vulnerable
newborn baby the foolhardy awful
inhumane nature of the government's
proposal that somehow you could use
pushbacks in the english channel without
putting lives at risk
newborn is a little girl called ayan how
old is this baby 40 days
we witnessed her being handed to police
and immigration officials at dungeness
it marked the end of one journey and the
start of another why risk her life and
her baby's life
england is the best life
from there ayan and her mother will most
likely taken to dover and the white
marquee processing facility called tug
haven
we obviously can't go inside here but
the monitors and watchdogs who have been
in have criticized these facilities as
being unsafe and unclean migrants are
only supposed to spend a few hours here
it's a short-term holding facility but
the recent surge in arrivals has seen
some stay for more than 24 hours
children and families are given priority
though as was the case with the latest
arrivals once processed they're given
short-term accommodation while they wait
for their asylum claims to be assessed
fingers crossed she will be
able to get asylum status for her and
her mum and they will be able to go on
and flourish as most people do once they
get asylum status
ayan and her family are iraqi kurds who
charities say have a good chance of
being granted asylum that can take
anywhere between six months and two
years oh wait many are clearly prepared
for iva bennett sky news dover